oh dear
we're just saying
oh my gosh okay guys
i do this on tick tock so i don't know
if it'll be as good on youtube
or if people are just going to flame me
but i do this thing where like i'm um
so i need to get something that's like
this
hmm
i think i'm like a child with these
lives
because i just have fun i don't know um
oh no
okay i guess we're going back down here
it'd be nice to have something like here
though
right like this would be cool
right
don't oh no no
all right
oh my god okay wait
wait wait hold up hold up hold up hold
up
okay we're gonna we're gonna put you
guys here clearly
i have issues
but what i do on
my tic tac lines
is every donation i sprint
now you could say
why don't you just sprint on your own
well hear me out
i'm motivated by two things one
looking hot
but unfortunately
i've never had a lot of them
i've never really looked at myself as
hot so i don't have that much
how do i put it
value like self-worth in my looks as
much
so it's not about driving
but you know what is money
oh you know what i should turn the
lights on in here what am i doing hold
on i'll be back one second
hold up hold up
okay
i'm back
uh
you just donated
me a like ten dollars wow okay 30
seconds sprint i was not expecting this
to work that fast
okay i'm gonna do the
speed on
we'll do nine i'm not that fast so
sprint for me is like speed nine
okay
ready go
so
oh my god
okay i'm gonna just keep going so
i'm 35 45 50.
i just hit 30 seconds so i'm just gonna
do a minute
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
two more seconds
five
four
three
two
one
oh my god
okay bulldog update
i have a dog center
in england
[Music]
i just wasn't expecting
two that fast wow
thank you guys i was so nice to you
been live for five minutes
i'm gonna do that every day
if you guys donate oh my god
you'll see me sprinting on the daily
like
hi
i need to get a better
phone holder thing while i'm home
i'd really like to have you guys
stood up over there so you can see me
running
maybe i will
drop a like drop a like guys
and this can be any size
donation hopefully
you donate a dollar
30 seconds rent
don't matter
so
i'm trying to undo all this christmas
weight
hey
should i put this on
how many miles do i do normally
uh i try to burn like 300 calories
so usually like three to four hundred
so usually i start with cardio i know
you're not supposed to
but i do because i hate cardio and i
know if i don't start with it i'm not
going to do it
so i start with cardio
and i do
walking running whatever till i burn
300 to 400 calories
and then i go left
and usually i'm at home so i don't have
a bar
but normally i would do
um
either squat or deadlift i know some
people like to do both on the same day i
don't um
and then either bench or incline bench
or push press
and then
i'll usually just add like two or three
like i try to do like five lifts
i don't have a crazy workout routine
otherwise i
i would have a much better body if i'm
being honest um
but that's usually what i do
sometimes if i'm tired
i do more or less
it just depends on the day
so
yeah
[Applause]
so right now i'm at 78 calories so
i don't really feel like running today
unless you guys pay me to
so
what i do
is i'll go do incline just to make it a
little bit harder
because i just have a hard time
with running i hate running
which is ironic because i play a lot of
sports you think right
what am i gonna freestyle
when i'm a little bit better at it maybe
thank you
okay
i love games
i love games
i kind of want to do like a workout game
maybe not now because i'm a
semi-pro athlete so when i go back
i don't know if i'll have time to do
this online but
if i wasn't i would totally do like a
for every donation i'll do something
type live
because
my backs
yeah i am
um i did it mostly
when i moved to england
um
i really didn't want to get vaccinated
one more okay
i'll tell you the story after i do the
sprint
all right i'm gonna go to speed
10 for this one because it's only one
so
when i get to speed 10 that's what i'm
going to start counting
okay ready
go
so it's 35.
[Laughter]
okay i more seconds guys
two
times
oh my god
okay
oh my god
[Applause]
did i go over well
you got more bang for your buck i guess
i wasn't sure because
the treadmill setting changed
so i was like i don't know exactly what
second it started
but
should i do these daily
25 bucks
in 15 minutes
can you guys donate like this
i'll be running damn near every day
you'll see me get so skinny
i don't care what anyone says
money is motivating
yeah i'm gonna run faster if i'm getting
paid
yeah what the hell
like
on my tic tac they're like
why don't you just do it
because you want to i'm like because i
don't
i clearly don't want to do it
at all
not even a little bit but
when i get a donation i'm like i have to
i have to
oh my gosh i
i'm about to hit a mile right now
it's on incline though so it's a little
bit
different
story i was going to tell you guys
before i ran
is running help my breathing
no because i do it wrong
supposed to breathe through your nose
when i run i breathe through my mouth
oh the back story that's what i was
talking about so
the reason i got vaccinated was because
if you don't you have to quarantine for
two weeks in the uk
and i was like
i was coming to school and stuff so late
that i was like eff it
and i thought i had to get it i didn't
realize it was optional
but
when i went there one i realized
i didn't have to get it so i got it for
nothing
and then two
they don't even really enforce the
quarantine
like how would they check
they're not gonna just show up at your
door
and so because of that like
i um
yeah i didn't even have to get
vaccinated but i did
so now i'm vaccinated
so hopefully i still have kids one day
so my mom was telling me that she was
like
you could be infertile
well i hope not i'd be real bummed out
[Applause]
it's not mandatory i don't think it's
mandatory anywhere in the u.s
unless you work for like a certain type
of company maybe
it's mandatory in new york for real
huh i did not know that
i'm so tired of the masks and everything
think coved
like i just wanted to go back to normal
again
so
oh you can't go any public places in new
york without a vax
i think that's probably like that in
downtown chicago but i live in
the suburbs
so
yeah that's not so much an issue for me
hey post all right
i'll answer that question after i do the
sprint i gotta do the sprint first
okay
all right i'm gonna tell you guys when i
start it
so i'm gonna get to speed ten
and then i'm gonna go
okay ready
all right
set
go
all right i got like five seconds i
think
i'm just sucking
i think i did it a little longer
oh god
okay i do it
extra because
i feel like
i'm not exactly sure when i started
and people are giving me their money
i'd rather do it for too long
than too short
because people are giving me their money
um
okay how do i post constant
content
consistently while busy
um
is it a habit
or something you do
that keeps you motivated um i'm broke
i know my parents are well off
i don't have their money
so look at my bank account i look at it
and there's not much there
and i know i gotta pay rent
so
partially one
two
um
oh there's five more
two i have
two years worth of tick tocks
so when i'm home
um
i post my old tic tocs
because
i i can't i don't have my equipment
and i use my phone i'm not afraid to use
my phone
and do unconventional [ __ ] like this
okay next sprint you guys ready
[Applause]
okay i'm gonna tell you when i start
i'm gonna get the speed 10
and then start
okay
all right that's ten
twenty
oh
all right
ugh
i won't pass out
i play sports which are way
should i do this every day
doing this for 22 minutes
34
that's crazy
you guys can be like my trainers
did you guys donate if i did this every
day
let me know in the comments
it's okay if the answer is no
less running for me
do you watch
all right i'm at
227 calories
so
i usually do 45 minutes or less of
cardia
um
so or whatever gets me to i try to get
350. usually i stop at 300
calories
you donut
dope i'm gonna do this tomorrow for sure
i have a huge paper
huge paper dude this week
oh my
god um
[Applause]
i've done this on tick tock a couple
times but
let me tell you
i must have ever made in an hour on
tick-tock from doing this
22 dollars
most i make here
34 30 minutes
not even
i like youtube
man
could even do
i might have fun would it be
if i did like a call-in show
so hear me out
you guys talk about like men's
self-improvement or whatever
and
how fun would it be if we did i don't
know how i would do this because i don't
know how i would set up the equipment
like i just use my phone now
so
but how fun would it be if we did like a
a call-in show and you could call in and
do the workout with me like live
so it's all like uh
when i can get more money yeah if you
want to send it to me on cash apps
hannah pearl davis my full name
h-a-n-n-a-h
p-e-a-r-l-g-a-b-i-s
if you want i'll take any
any form
but it's the idea i'm just talking live
like we always talk about
self-improvement and all that stuff but
it's more like
you don't really know if your creators
are actually like doing this stuff
so what if
i do it with you guys like
there's like a live show almost where we
work out together
problem is
when i get back to england i'm going to
be spending like 40 hours a week in the
gym
so
i don't know if i'll have time to do
that
every day but like once a week
collins i'm just bouncing off ideas
you guys like that idea
yay
sometimes i think about
when my grandchildren see this chat
be like
my grandma was crazy
also if you're in here
put a like in the chat give me the 15
likes
please
you don't you don't have to but if you
want i could be nice it's like seven to
you
i've seen three more
to like the live
or not you know do you do you
well it's got to be in the gym too
unless it's like homework outs well
it'll just be the cardio section
i don't
could be an at-home workout i don't know
i didn't think about it through because
i don't think i could do it at a gym
because when i'm at school i don't have
access to like uh
i do have access to a gym but it's like
full of people
i don't think i'd have the equipment
there to pull a live show
so it'd just have to be an at-home
workout
i feel like if you get the donation
gifts
i do not get the reference sorry
i'm just thinking out loud here people
this no don't dislike my video
please
all right
guys three more likes give me the 15
likes
13 likes thank you thank you two more
two more give me the 15.
please please
i'm on england no i'm in chicago
i go to england and
i'm the sixth i fly back i'm back for a
break christmas hanging out with the fam
16 likes thank you guys
i knew we could get there
i knew i knew some of you would come
through
i had a feeling
chicago well i'm not in downtown chicago
i live in
the suburbs very different environment
you don't even got to be careful here
because it's pretty safe
i mean you should always be careful but
you know what i'm saying
okay i think i'm gonna go
for
maybe five more minutes
so if you guys want to see me sprint
donate now
or hold forever hold your peace
hyde park no that's even closer to the
city than i am
i'm like 45 minutes from the city
all the dramas that you can't listen to
they might think you're the ops
i just did a collab with fredo bang i'm
so excited afraid of bang i'm so excited
to release i have to edit the video
but
i got like
a ton of reactions
from with him
ops
pearl davis one
is my cash no it's um hold on let me let
me pull it up okay sorry i'm back it's
hannah
h-a-n-n-a-h
pearl p-e-a-r-l
davis d-a-v-i-s
so it's my full name hannah
most people don't know my first name's
hannah
h-a-n-n-a-h
pearl p-e-a-r-l
davis d-a-v-i-s
full name
please don't hack me with that
information
okay
i thought all this time your first name
was pearl
no it's a nickname it started in college
because there was two hannah's on the
team
and after that i just like liked it
because
i felt like
less people were named pearl so i felt
like that branding was just better
but now my first name's hannah
my family calls me hannah my friends
call me pearl it's like usually depends
where i'm at the front if i met that
friend
before college they call me hannah after
college to call me parole
so
just depends
even i think my pinned video on my page
i introduced myself as hannah pearl
i just liked the name just pearly things
because
i'm kind of odd i've always been a
little odd so in college when
i would do something weird they'd be
like oh it's just pearly things and i
just like liked that name
oh someone just sent me a dollar
okay guys i'm cash app so
30 second sprint
thank you for the dollar donation
give me one second i'm gonna
up it and then so what's gonna happen is
i'm gonna move it to speed 10
and then i'm going to do the 30 seconds
okay
okay
i got it yeah
i'm doing your sprint now
okay
god
okay 10 seconds
20 seconds
30 seconds
okay
did someone else send me something i
just got a notification
hold on
okay another one
you're just donating
i didn't have to run
well
no i have to run
now you donated twice
i run twice
i don't
i don't promise the people something
and i give it to them
it's called my word
but
second donation
i appreciate it what's going on here
you guys donate i run for 30 seconds
so
someone just sent me a 20 donation
i'm about to run for 30 seconds
so
i'll tell you when i started
okay ready
okay
okay
[Music]
uh
you'll be back next workout session
good luck in england stay safe
thank you i'll probably do it while i'm
home
rest of the week
can i dunk oh god no i wish
girls are dunking left and right
nowadays when i was in school that was
unheard of
you never met girls like a dunk
okay guys
i think i'm done
oh thank you so much
for the donations guys
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep doing this this
was crazy i was not expecting to get
that many
i didn't get a single complaint usually
i get the
why are you just motivated to do it
duh i'm motivated by money what do you
think
obviously
okay
bye guys
thank you you're so nice